unter großem medialen interesse besucht
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
die soldatinnen und soldaten im
assistenzeinsatz am grenzübergang
nickelsdorf um sich ein bild der lage
vor ort zu machen
dabei unterstützen die eingesetzten
soldaten unter anderem die polizei bei
der einreisekontrolle beim überprüfen
alle notwendigen dokumente
besonders wichtig für die
verteidigungsministerin ist die
durchhaltefähigkeit des bundesheeres bei
solchen assistenzeinsätze bekannt
gegeben
die erstmalig in der geschichte
erstmalige aufbietung von teilen der
miliz die auch dafür sorgen soll dass
diese durchhaltefähigkeit der
soldatinnen und soldaten hier an diesem
hotspot weiterhin gewährleistet werden
kann
sie werden dann auch für
sicherheitspolizeiliche agenten zum
einsatz kommen
das österreichische bundesheer sorgt für
die österreicherinnen und österreicher
führte an sicherheit ist immer da wenn
es zur assistenz angefordert wird egal
ob von den sicherheitsbehörden oder von
den gesundheitsbehörden die österreicher
können sich auf ihr bundesheer verlassen